when a long-running TV series comes to
an end the fans can sometimes get a
little bit emotional but plenty of Game
of Thrones enthusiasts aren't just sad
about the show ending they're mostly
feeling angry about how it all wrapped
up that unrest has given rise to a
petition demanding HBO remake the eighth
and final season with a whole new team
of writers a tall order that they hope
at least sends a clear message to the
people in charge of the show business
you don't want to see they do anything
to protect their babies the online
petition gained international attention
as a funnel episode of the series drew
near by the day after the divisive
finale it had already received well over
a million signatures one person who was
unaware of the petitions existence was
the actress whose unexpected character
turn arguably started the intense fan
outcry in the first place Daenerys
Targaryen actress Emilia Clarke was told
about the petition when she sat down for
an interview with The New Yorker during
which he gained Lee offered her ideas
for a hypothetical do-over but Clarke
also said she's quote in no position to
critique the geniuses I've written eight
seasons worth of wonderful stuff not a
true story necessarily Clarke revealed
that she would have loved if Daenerys
interacted with a handmaiden missandei
and their greatest enemy Cersei
Lannister more than she did during
season eight she also said she wanted to
quote see a bit more discussion between
characters drawing the controversial
fifth episode of the season which
followed Daenerys and the Allied forces
as they stormed King's Landing when the
city surrendered in a peaceful manner
during the climactic episode the mother
of dragons suddenly made a he'll turn to
watch sheer madness ordering her dragons
are burned down everything in sight
Clarke has since said that Danny's
tumbling into madness was inevitable but
she would have enjoyed additional
conversations being included in between
all the action she explained to the new
yorker the genocide was there that was
always going to happen and I just seem
that we are more than happy to contently
sit there and watch ten minutes of two
people talking because it's beautiful I
just wanted to see a bit more of that
Clarke also expressed the desire in her
idea of a hypothetical do-over to see
Downey's quote last images being nassif
kind of a hopeful childlike love before
she dies in the arms of a lover / nephew
John Snow who tragically slays her out
of a certainty that she'll cause more
harm than good to the people of Westeros
Clarke said the Nerissa's death was a
quote shocker to read but the actress
also admitted that she isn't sure the
character could have had a more try
intending as she put it I always knew
that the show was never going to satisfy
everyone the stories are too fast the
characters too complex the show is in a
certain way divisive whose side are you
on also if you're pleasing everyone then
it's probably quite tepid but to me it
seemed that the only way it could end it
couldn't have been easy for Clark to
come to terms with what happened to a
character whom she has played since 2011
on the final two episodes of Game of
Thrones her response to the petition
asking for a redo is incredibly
level-headed which is admirable
considering Clark's tenaris was the only
major character to die in the final
episode it's unlikely that those who
hated Game of Thrones final season will
suddenly change their minds after
hearing klux response to the online
backlash but perhaps a diplomatic
disposition might inspire them to ease
up a little if the woman who had to play
the character who went mad killed
thousands and got stabbed to death over
the course of two episodes can remain
calm about the situation the people who
only had to witness the calamity should
be able to do the same check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about Game of Thrones
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]